hey what's up where are we going oh
we're going into Civic Development Group
and what we do is we call our people and
chisel them out of money
Patrick and I both work at this
telemarketing place
um this 14 year old kid making calls on
behalf of Charities it's like a big ass
cookout money
I didn't think I was doing anything bad
at all now Lisa these families they do
need your support the business model is
defrauding the most vulnerable in this
country it was a big time scam this is
capitalism
we need to show the world what this
place really does the media and the
government haven't been able to stop
them so now it's up to us
Pat and I had vowed to expose the
industry and it seemed to be evolving
into something bigger and weirder than
ever political action campaigns rovo
calls Federal Credit commission Congress
this guy does not want to talk to us so
we figured we'd get something to eat oh
there he is let's leave the food go go
go go go
[Music]
regulating telemarketing is like
regulating Somalia pirates
this can't be done
you're like a whistleblower they don't
want us here bro dude let's just go sin
there's no turning back
they were calling and the initials were
cash so they would tell you make the
check out the
c-a-s-h wake up smell the coffee money
money money all the time what I'm
thinking about
[Music]